uh and it's also not crowder but there
is something that happened with crowder
today that i mean
we were tagged in i guess we'll do that
first um
so this person who's only like 400
subscribers
after this this is after the the bump
from this getting retweeted so much
uh this is a lucas santo bouche bougie
bourget
boujee because there's a thing on the e
there's the thing on the e boujee
so whatever bougie uh i will say this
and i won't say i'm not gonna
i will just say this somebody in the
chat room got the
person right but i can't but i will not
say who it is there's too many in
they'll never figure it out yeah well
it's clear
because the guy said ag luck it's not
it's not age log
um as the or as the oh no anyway
so um he tweeted out
she she she tweeted out when i did no i
mean because if this is a trans person i
don't know why they look like greg
allman
yeah they they really do they have a
they have a beard too
um [ __ ] looks like uh looks like
[ __ ] barry windham
so uh they said
when i identified as a trans teenager i
was approached by uh stephen crowder
tech crowder
soliciting sex for me i was 17 he
offered me a thousand dollars and i
couldn't turn it down
i was homeless and desperate he has
since told me he'd sue me if i spoke out
and and has slandered me to filth today
i speak my truth
my truth crowder is unapologetically
hateful towards trans people
and that was prevalent in our experience
together it was the worst few minutes of
my life
his sustain for trans women and women in
general is dangerous
stephen crowder hashtag me too hashtag
enough is enough
um not buying it
i don't buy it either i i i don't and we
look make fun of crowder we'll probably
continue
to joke with the most terrible comedy
sketches but i don't buy this no
i i not even for a [ __ ] second
whoever tagged us i retweeted it and i
said look nobody likes to make fun of
stephen crowder more than me
but i don't buy it i don't believe this
d-gen i don't believe it
it's and i'll tell you why one of the
reasons
crowder was trending late last night um
uh crowder was tr uh it was trending and
it was all about
uh crowder goes into a gym dressed as a
trans person
crowder crowder trans people trans
people crowder and then all of a sudden
within an hour this person's like
i'm trans and steven crowder to me for a
thousand dollars and you're like wow
well first off it's not for a thousand
dollars it's processing well like it's
i know i was just trying to be i guess
about it but like
so crowder the trump supporter
crowder the guy who made fun of carlos
mazza
this awful crowder is by the way it's
just let's be honest the biggest bully
on the internet i mean he's just so mean
to everybody
and he's also had blair white on um so
crowder
when they tried to take him down about
the carlos mazza thing he didn't pile on
then
when everybody was trying to cancel all
these trump guys he didn't come out then
he waited until there was a specific
trending thing about trans people and it
was like
i'm trans and my truth and he paid i
don't buy it i think this person was
cloud chasing
it this person's full of [ __ ] and i look
i would love to
pile on crowder not in that way but
right in a comedy way and uh i don't buy
it and i was telling royce off the air
i honestly think that crowder is a
closeted gay guy
i think crowder's one of those closeted
gay guys that has never
or barely had sex with dudes i think
he's so wound up
that's why he's such a her
because he's not having the gay sex he
should be having um
so i just don't i don't buy it i think
he's uh
i definitely think he's a closet case
but this this is just too
shittily timed yeah i don't buy it
either the video they're referring to
that was trending was like five years
ago crowder went to a gym dressed as a
woman or something like that
we've made fun of that video though yeah
yeah we have uh that's the video they're
they're talking about but
i i really i don't buy this this feels
like it's somebody piling on
and trying to um make
make themselves famous and it's one of
those things where
there's no proof you know what i mean
there there's nothing other than
this person's word you know yeah and
even if you don't have proof from back
then you don't have proof
of him threatening you
right exactly how did he threaten you
yeah because most of these people get
caught
it's not because the original thing it's
because then they're like you have to
[ __ ] tell anybody about this all suit
you know what i mean like he doesn't
have those emails
just seems a lot of it seems very odd to
me
uh and yeah and then i mean that's
that's i'm just going through the thread
here and it's not
see they tweeted that with 17 hours ago
and i don't i don't really see
has anyone uh got dave landau's uh take
on this
his new co-host no no they haven't
um but yeah that's it that's the only
thing that they've that they've tweeted
this person
is this is this is them
so you said you wanted to know what they
look like and that's them
it's like a transberry windom yeah
or one of the beegees yes
we're reforming the four horsemen but
they're gonna be trans
this person's never really talked about
crowder before just like george floyd
stuff black lives matter stuff
stuff like that um that's pretty much
all i see
yeah it's this person's full of [ __ ] i
don't buy it um
again i i wouldn't even given it a
second thought anyway
but i also happen to [ __ ] notice last
night that he was trending
and everybody was like uh wow auntie
trans much
and then all of a sudden this guy's like
i am a trans and this guy paid me for
sex and it's like stop it dude
just stop i do think yeah crowder's a a
gay dude but
i don't even think crowder would be into
trans people i think crowd would just be
into dudes
yeah i mean i i like i said i i don't i
don't know i don't know what he's into
or not into but there's just something
about this one like you said the way it
was timed and
the way that it came out that i i really
really doubt it
you know